[Musik]
[Applaus]
da haben einige spieler machen also mach
dann halt immer so denn halt grad
ich habe halt nur stoffe kriegen wir
nicht halt so machen aber wenn ich so
hintergangen aber so wenn ich so normal
bin und für ihre leute
das bild das bild perfekt zum beispiel
hier sollen die untertanen aus sondern
bilder und dann ist ein kratzer und das
runnymede updates juni aussagen
und wieso land das nicht auf instagram
ist so perfekt wie gesagt einfach
perfekt ist das perfekt aber das ist
einfach es liegt ja sozusagen mini auge
macht kleben aber ist aber in vermisst
sein online ich hat nur wenig mit seinem
alltag als mikro lehrling gemein im
kosmos der sozialen medien ist junis
model und entertainer zehntausende
vorwiegend weibliche fans folgen ihm auf
plattformen wie instagram snapshot oder
tik tok
letzteres ist eine playback ab auf der
hauptsächlich teenies ihre lippen
synchron zu einem song bewegen
[Musik]
ich mache halt auch irgendwo dort zum
unterhalt ich habe nicht am morgen
aufwache weiß ich schon mit aufstrich
bewege fernbedienung mit weg seien die
lektoren sein die neben jack lemmon
alles ab menge model spiele ich auch als
game oder so aber es hat meistens schon
einfach zucht will man nicht einmal ins
gramm bin bin ich da nicht nur so 2
minute oder nicht nur zwei minuten aber
bin ich halb stunde stunden auch auf
instagram vielleicht einiges anderes
genial gemacht
spannend und wenn die person
ich bin irgendwie einhändig sind steuern
und wesentlichen um 10 5
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was runter im ring von snapshot und es
lebe die day4 herzlich wie eine
zigarette raucht macher mittel versucht
genau
doch was bis ich dich nach märz zeigen
öffentlichkeit nach dem islam
veröffentlicht das die analyse war die
haut um ihren privat an privat und staat
machen braucht ihn interessiert was sie
machen ja aber was gibt's die ersten
kurzgeschichten treffer heran
ich kannte das ein bisschen stimmbruch
ja aber es wundert schüttorfer sammeln
doch länger mit will ich hab dann mache
das so und jetzt stehe ich halt einfach
lief ich damit auf den bildern auch ein
besseres gerät einfach das ist klar wir
bauen muss als wenn ich mitmache
aber wenn sind fertig sich sitzen
das ist ja da wiederum möglich wieder
mit instagram streaming krippenplatz
denn die sucht nach likes treibt ihn an
junis verbringt viel zeit damit sich in
allen lebenslagen selber zu
fotografieren oder sich fotografieren zu
lassen
seine beste freundin hat sich längst an
junis elfi money gewöhnt und alles so
knapp wurde genau und das zeigt im haus
liegt der öbb cool und mehr als man
sagen das ist einfach das soeben hat sie
nicht
gott zu helfen
ja ja das ist sie arrogant
ja okay was man jetzt machen
kylie jenner hat es vom tv sternchen zur
multi-millionärin geschafft dank
zielstrebiger vermarktung ihres lebens
und ihrer eigenen beauty produkte in den
sozialen medien
die hatte reichen mit dir was sie will
ihre paläste so also ab da sind alle für
die qualität wie viel asche zu scannen
sind über die finanzierung der momentan
miss moneypenny jannik nowak dem so
schön wenn sie sich schminkt sie hat der
nokian cool für jahr also für mich stand
auch schon nordkurve die nasse und ich
bin halt wenn man sich sowohl auf das
doch machen was man will aber sie sollte
das vorbild sich jetzt dass nicht die
falsche botschaft für junge frauen
das kommt schon für andere so überall
auf mich konzern zu sie macht das hat
mir sehr gefallen wie sie sich so besser
fühlt und ich machen will ich mich
wohler so viel mit den selber besser hat
gefallen
auch michelle postet fortwährend fotos
und videos von sich auf dem bilder
netzwerk instagram hat sie 5000
sogenannte followers also abonnenten die
ihrem profil folgen auf der teenie
plattform tik tok sind es sogar 72
tausend mit effekten selber was man
macht was macht das video im internet
geld verdienen das ist und was macht ja
[Musik]
genau und für die likes you like the
brutal hört die uni-mensa objektes mit
dem metro abzuziehen
der umgang mit sozialen medien als thema
im unterricht ziel ist die
sensibilisierung der schülerinnen und
schüler für manipulierte bilder und
versteckte werbebotschaften
häufig gehen social media größten
kooperationen ein und werden gesponsert
auch younes zwar kann er seinen
lebensunterhalt nicht mit dem einkommen
als onlinestar bestreiten
aber er bekommt markenklamotten sowie
accessoires kostenlos gestellt im wissen
dass sein style von den kids kopiert
wird
ja das wird und die der anderen
ja bekannt gemacht und gedacht
also original
[Musik]
und wir könnten sachen halt gemacht so
die handtasche weg
[Musik]
doch sport
jonas popularität im virtuellen wirkt
sich auch auf sein reales leben aus wo
er auftaucht zittern die fans das handy
was mit dem bild
bis zur fensterkante
und natürlich soll das akkordeon ist
straff anja vor bekannt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viele followers und klicks auf tik tok
machten aus jonas vor zwei jahren ein
nationales thema
autogramme waren gestern heute macht
man's 11
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit der ära prägen ähnliches harmonie ab
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dass die spö sich das thema verstehe es
nicht so einfach dass es außer schmiss
private labors rekordmeister zudem
staubfinger und ja ja
fonic meldung zusammenschau milchstraße
zusammen monika wird einfach rechnet
erweisen sie auch als privatmann einfach
hinter überreicht kämpferin
[Musik]
so muss bringt deutet also ab und zu
wenn mir langweilig ist nachhaltig so
klug wenn er klickt man halt genau
denken so war wie schon gegen malta und
als kirche mache denn ich mag die
strecke so war das habe ich gemacht dann
allein zehn schüsse nicht halt irgendwie
retro geht also ich bin ja auch so schön
kärnten jetzt gleich als mein nächster
zeit problemlos klären so bedeute video
und eine hatte klassenerhalt wieso
bekommt es mit 50 likes und ya konan
geben mit auf mehr bekommt aus dem 20
flexishop ist alles will ich meine
arbeit gemacht und mexiko autos quartal
anders
ich möchte einfach den sieg machte da so
und deshalb ziehe ich war jetzt 50
seiteneingang ich sie heute froh gewesen
wenn man wird ob ich vielleicht so
[Musik]
herzen fliegen younes nicht nur in form
von likes zu selbst seine mutter ist
überrascht wie viele fans für ihren sohn
schwärmen strahlung getroffen
es gibt ja immer so
und wenn ja was für sie denn nicht dass
dann ist man nicht so einfach nicht aus
also mit social media sorgen
jetzt meint junis der ohne vater
aufwuchs lebt heute gemeinsam mit seiner
mutter ihrem neuen mann und dem kleinen
halbbruder zusammen
vielleicht ja auch so aus
immer wieder mit sachen einfach sachlich
sache sache mit viel geld und es zum
werk der zerstörung und einfach immer
noch klar weniger
wie geschaffen bei ja ja ja sogar und
erzeugen so dass er sagt ja und ja dann
hin vielleicht ja mehr stress kraus
zieht für den soli stieg sorgen jetzt
für den christian mitnehmen durchgesagt
bespuckt gedacht für sie könnten also
mit zwei kriegen sie einfach als die
gesamten 50 uhr schaut
usa ja
[Musik]
zelebrieren des eigenen ichs wie jonas
so sucht auch michelle in den sozialen
medien nach selbstbestätigung wer likes
und voller poesie akt muss aus der
bilderflut herausstechen bewährtes
mittel aufreizende posen
ich habe das einfach nicht so als
opposition sind dass ich so bin ich und
bist du trägst du trägst und dann so was
kann ich dir gemacht stellte lena senges
jung und dumm
der stratege michael sailer da geht es
damals nicht tätowiert der stadt yuma
nahm not my story wie so viele menschen
urteilen aber einfach nicht wissen wer
du wirklich bist aber du könnte schon
sagen ich verabschiede mich ganz aufhöre
so ja auch langweilig wenn ihr mit dem
handy buchen handelt dass überhaupt ein
bisschen händler machen was man nicht
löschen
ich brauche das vom in israel
auch chiara präsentiert sich auf ihrem
instagram account öffentlich im bikini
geschätzt also zumal bucher also hat
eigentlich bin ich dafür dass man in dem
buch haben muss das erstmal nicht denkt
will er die fitness models sind so
rüberbringen dass und lara buschmann ich
stehe man zur bucht aber es ist ja
völlig macht er nicht er kann ziehen da
werden der grund ist einfach got a es
war escada com bietet dadurch die grafik
sieht lag fast nur friedlich eigentlich
auch gern vor diesem verfahren habe
viele spieler besser gemacht dass ich
auch wie zu tag so nach dem vorbild
ihrer instagram idole will michelle ihre
lippen erneut aufspritzen lassen
der eingriff ist mit der unterschrift
der eltern ab 16 jahren erlaubt die 350
franken teure lippenvergrößerung ist für
mich schnell gratis als gegenleistung
macht die schülerin auf ihren social
media accounts für die beautyklinik
werbung
irgendwas lehrer wenden
was bringt sie extrem trainer haben sie
an marketing- und
mund-zu-mund-propaganda und hilfsdienste
influenza und die kollegen aber es geht
für die jungs hier in generation in sich
keine kenne sich auch neue trend und ich
danken es gibt sie dem singkreis ziehen
würde sich auch wieder am universum
bohrung sei es wenn sie das macht und
gehörte später bereut im halbjahr ist es
wird zu viel puste größere und es bleibt
für immer
zudem ist der aktionsradius produkt und
wird jetzt aber bären oder so starter
weg indem erfahrung mit also hier ist
noch ein bisschen drin
hier an den seiten es fast nicht also
gar nichts - ich zeig dir das mal an
mich selber dass das selber spürt hier
auch nicht mehr
eigentlich ist es auch normal dass hier
an den seiten nichts ist weil er stritt
sich ja auch immer gar nicht so viel mit
einem lichtwecker das war schön gesehen
also nichts anderes zählt hat folge
perfekt delikt war ja ja das ist ja das
was ich weiß was ich meinte zwar einfach
ein bisschen bisschen mehr kontur
was würdest du dir gar nicht passen und
deswegen ihr herz ist viel weiter
auseinander und deswegen kann man das so
schön so schön betonen dass hat hast du
nicht gucken
du hast dein spiegel muss mich in den
handy gucken
so ich fange hier an dem mundwinkel an
wie immer gehen wir einmal frei bis oben
in dein herz dann machen wir im moment
ein bisschen auf und schön zu bleiben
tief luft und
[Musik]
wie gefällt es dir perfekt und spree das
natürlich entscheidungen bett naja
[Musik]
seit fünf jahren ist chiara auf
instagram aktiv zeigt öffentlich die
veränderung ihres körpers von der nur 25
kilo leichten magersüchtigen zur
durchtrainierten sportlerin mit den
vorher nachher bildern will chiara
zeigen dass es einen weg aus der
krankheit gibt
doch die plattform hilft auch ihr über
53.000 instagram nutzer folgen ihr
schicken virtuelle herzchen und zuspruch
pro bild bekommt die studentin zwischen
1500 und 4000 likes abregen trotzdem die
klerikale vielleicht über das ich selber
habe schon wenig selbstvertrauen sehr
zurückhaltender mensch normalerweise
bleiben eigentlich nicht animiert
überwunden es macher valley band einer
helfer kabel schon selbstkritisch und
die war nicht wenig wertschätzung für
mich selber und das ist glaube ich schon
dass mir gott dort wenn ihre positive
kommentare bekommt ja likes fürs
aussehen der körperkult im internet
birgt gefahren
je schlanker umso erfolgreicher lautet
die botschaft zahlreicher post welcher
junge frauen und mädchen zum abnehmen
und hungern animieren mit fatalen folgen
schlussendlich selbst macht eigentlich
anruf sie abriss ist bestätigung dass
man es schafft wo andere nicht schaffen
die zum teil des alten königs ist
anorexie ist schlussendlich den oa
wettbewerb werden
indirekt ein ich selbst verstehe ich sie
also amys eltern akzeptieren können habe
bestimmte sachen aktionäre können in
leber und durch es nicht es sollte doch
ab und verschwindet langsam langsam
verschwinden wie sie nun mal da wie
nahrung hat für chiara mittlerweile eine
neue bedeutung bekommen auf instagram
kostet die 21-jährige rezepte und bilder
ihrer gerichte food fotos sind für sie
weit mehr als nur ein trend als
magersüchtige fotografierte sie jede
ihrer mahlzeiten und stellte diese ins
netz
viele bilder basken ecken aber jetzt wo
tritt hinaus geht zahlen ins auto setzen
also unser recht ist ein halber besorgt
in joghurt also das sagen zwar wachse in
dem das ist mit mir nicht zu mittag zwei
teams nach hamburg um mit spengler und
den trecker unterwegs besser
ganz nah vom instagram man nie wirklich
alles fotografiert ich habe weder tage
das ist für mich ist das also meter zog
sie das in essen können
sie ist wie also ok gott die
antrainierte sich gestern hat ihn kann
ich so ist also den ist den hang ist es
aber wenn ihr biss ist woanders her hin
den darf ist also für mich ist es wenn
es mit dem man sie und besser
hallo möchten wir fragen
ich habe aber alles betäubt bekommen
jetzt ist erst mal fertig jetzt bestellt
und jeden monat gehen geht monat ja nie
so einfach weg
[Musik]
das ist ja so einfach will ich denke
positiv
du sagst das geht zurück nach geht es
daher in die schule und so weiter das
musst du schon das musst du denn schon
ertragen können aber wenn es zurückgeht
denn das gute ist ja misere erlaubnis
und glich roman josi wird sie denn so
mache wildtiere so quandt oder mit 18 ii
wird sich denn machen wenn ich bin jetzt
weniger der typ der das ja und die
gleise über hülle ist ja und das wird
sich auch wieder abbau ist gott ja auch
wieder mit zurück und von da
ich habe meine enkelin unwahrscheinlich
gerne und ich finde dass das ein
bildhübsches mädchen und das ist immer
das dass ich das nicht ganz das
begreifen nicht ganz weil sie denkt
immer sie sehen nicht so schön
darum macht sonst wird sich ja gar nicht
machen und schminkt ist sehr sehr schön
ein durchtrainiertes hinterteil liegt
dank instagram und co im trend auch bei
chiara der lohn für das haut core
training extra likes für die kehrseite
das phänomen der selbst fotografierten
hintern hat einen namen berri eine
kombination aus dem wort bat zu deutsch
vor und self ii das ist die band queen
so sieht sie es erfunden und was hat's
erfunden hat sie es perfekt in szene so
richtig gehütet ahgz nur mal wieder was
können vielleicht der falsche ist diese
hinterteil das einfach die ganze zeit
nehmen sie ganz echten irgendwer gottes
samsung derzeit in den kopf geschossen
eigentlich hat dann versucht verlagere
gesucht sport ja also erwartet jahrelang
ist der erp software und annina kann man
immer noch hier haben wir also dann wenn
es mal nicht gemacht hatte haben wir
ziemlich schlecht fühlt aber es ist
mittlerweile ganz anders es ist kann mir
sagen ja gern bewegen
eine woche nachdem michelle sich die
lippen machen ließ sind nun die haare
dran
also ja ich bin eigentlich perfekt wurde
klar wir hatten auch nicht größe und
aufbau aber sind männer natürlich und
mit frau eines ergebnisse schulden zu
haben
nfc chip und so und jetzt garnicht
jacket das sie gemacht sind wie sein
sohn abdel azim unterschrieb ist
als ich dann in den job seit diesem tag
machten zurück weil die künstlichen
haarsträhnen gelitten haben lässt michel
diese herausnehmen wehmütig die blonde
mähne hat ihr stets viele likes beschert
ein video brachte es sogar auf 107000
herzchen
der haus und ich sehe mich durch
buchbar wenn das team cup auf diese
hatte
und die frage warum du das machst
bilderfolge einem post jo gerner
deswegen mit teilweise auch schon
irgendwie ist es nicht zeigen wir
relativ aufbauen die tagesform in leber
und die finden sich jetzt nicht
versteckt haben jetzt viele medien kann
einfach immer gut 1000 fotos mit ihnen
aber das ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vielleicht mit dem chance gibt die man
besserer hin dass zwei jahre zu bilden
so einfach zum auch im prozess sollen
bilder
mein hochschule rücken frei
was genau wir sind prozent
ich weiß es ganz genau war oder daher
die post
ja ich weiß genau so genau provoziere
aber ich merke für eigentlich dass es
sich einfach bei mir schlüssig mercedes
strich sting will er noch genauso wie
gemacht bin ich mache und was wird
später provokation bezwang
also also leichter so verloren vor allem
weil da er weiß ganz genau dass kurz
verloren
und irgendwo drauf bezirk hat also zur
kommt nach soviel ist das obligate
partys 11 wer seine fans bei der stange
halten will muss regelmäßig neues bieten
schon die idee was nicht ständig von der
[Gelächter]
sonne sex skandal
[Musik]
um seine medienpräsenz zu erhöhen
täuschte junis während eines live
streams sex vor
tausende haben zugehört und geneigt im
nachhinein musste younes öffentlich
einräumen dass das ganze nur ein pr
trick war um aufmerksamkeit zu
generieren
[Musik]
younes nächste selbst vermarktungs
aktion ein fantreffen ihr idol steht vor
ihnen
für die kids ist dass die große chance
auf ein gemeinsames elfi oder sogar ein
playback video für die eigene online
galerie
[Musik]
junis der unter dessen 18 jahre alt
geworden ist präsentiert sich im neuen
look mitbringe und frisch aufgespritzten
lippen
für den auftritt bekommt er zwar keine
gage aber einen erneuten
popularitätstief
aber du musst jetzt lag am 30
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dafür war sonst noch was
[Gelächter]
was macht dir ausgebucht und das spritzt
[Applaus]
das gefühl du andere schon mehr die man
sich machen
ich bin ich mit linien mit prävention
ali machte die derzeit wieder wenn die
zahlen immer schön einfach so normal
wir haben wenig und ja das ist das
einzige wo momentan meinen kopf und dann
dank stamm besprochen
ich weiß eine weniger jahre das kind
sich das rad sicher verändere aber
momentan bin ich so mache
massenhaft anerkennung und zuneigung
junis bekommt von seinen fans heute das
was er in seiner kindheit vermisste
[Musik]
rostock nicht welche zukunft wo ernst
die ertrags zwei wochen fragt aber große
gedanken ihn nicht publik machte war
zuvor aber das wären dann keine e-mails
sonne verstanden habe wird zu einer
vernichtung bronze gewann verloren hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]